lost he just kind of ran out of ideas he
wasn't able to formulate plans uh as
well as magnus and uh he just couldn't
deal with the change of pace of the game
and ivanka's right we do open with the
king's pawn one e4 and that's met by the
sicilian defense by magnus okay bringing
his knight out this is magnus's world
championship repertoire from 2018 uh
okay the black pawn now pushing forward
after white's bishop i'm not keen on
this bishop moving to that square it's a
very viable opening but i think it falls
into magnus's advantage he's going to go
into some kind of maneuvering game maybe
he'll get the bishop pair i don't know
okay so this again one of the most
topical openings in chess all the top
players all the top grandmasters in the
world seem to debate this opening with
white's bishop coming out
so i understand that dude is going into
something quite fashionable but as
ivanka mentions magnus is not going to
be surprised here at all so dude it
needs to be direct and he needs to
surprise the world champion get him out
of his comfort zone but as you can see
by the speed of moves magnus not
surprised and okay white pushing pawns
in the center black challenging and
doing the same both sides meanwhile have
developed quite naturally both sides
have castled duda however at least he's
gaining some space in the center of the
board white has a nice pawn chain
pointing uh towards the center and
black's knight now occupying a very
strong square so both sides have reason
to be happy but this is still very well
known territory
i've seen dozens and dozens of grand
master games in this position white's
bishop coming out just solidifying the
center white bishop not so active just
needs to control the central squares the
uh white pawn chain especially needs to
survive if duda wins this game and i'm
expecting magnus to maybe bring his
queen out
and a couple of moves here maybe you can
trade a set of pawns first
yeah and uh that trading the pawns is
what magnus played uh in his game
against fabian caruana in from
tattlesteel 2022 so very recently and
he's
confident because he's doing exactly the
same
so he re i like it when grandmasters
believe in their opening choices and
what they've played earlier it kind of
shows confident now
in that particular game white actually
defended the bishop with the queen by
moving it
to the square in front of the rook
so it wasn't the main move though the
main move was actually to play bishop
takes knight which again i'm not so sure
about because it does fall into
magnus's goal of getting those long-term
advantages maybe in this one it will be
the bishop pair and we saw yesterday how
great he was with the bishop pair yeah
even in close positions yeah actually
you're right there ivanka the two wins
that magnus got both times he obtained
the bishop and he's done the same here
as well if you notice white's light
square bishop now traded itself off for
the black knight and yes black has
bishops currently the black dart squad
bishop a bit blocked in just staring at
a wall of white pawns but long term
later in the game that might well become
a big big factor
so magnus has a reason to be happy
meanwhile duda
he's been slightly slower he's played
quite quickly up to this point but he's
slightly slower than magnus but he
should have predicted this position
because magnus played it in one of the
most important games of his uh year so
far in 2022 just a couple of months ago
so duda hopefully he's within his
homework he should certainly have been
studying this exact position this
morning uh
okay meanwhile now he's retreated one of
the white knights to challenge black's
strong knight in the center and uh if we
see a trade of knights then we'll go
into that maneuvering phase that iranka
was talking about
kind of stylistically characteristically
that all favors magnus though and magnus
just ignoring the nitrate brings his
bishop out
we're not following that game anymore
we're not following that game and uh
magnus well he's done his signature move
hasn't he where he's kind of gone into a
main line
but
around about uh move 12 or 12 he's kind
of not gone for the main line anymore
instead he's kind of played the second
option so
this isn't the most popular move
usually black was actually capturing the
knight now
duda is maybe on his own and he's going
to be assessing why
people played knight takes night before
in the past and he'll be trying to
figure things out and you figured out
magnus carlsen's secret so around move
12 is when he surprises well
it tends to be some kind of thing like
he'll go into the main line for maybe
seven to 12 moves and then he'll choose
something else as well that's very
natural but at the same time got a
little bit of venom
he did exactly the same in the world
championship match against nepomiacci uh
back in november he would play the
absolute main line but then as ivanka
mentions sometime between move eight and
twelve he'll play something a bit
a bit rare maybe the third most popular
move or the fourth most popular move
just because then he can pretty much
guarantee that his opponents haven't
studied that before
so he lets them get to a playable
position and then he surprises them and
then the psychological blow the
psychological shock may be even greater
for the opponents and uh magnus for sure
he studied this bishop move before as
yomaka mentions not the most popular
move but it does feel like duda now is
on his own so he can't rely duda purely
on what the computer told him is the
best move or what his coaches told him
is the best move dude is on his own just
uh has to be creative now to find a
solution and uh if we do see a trade of
knights maybe magnus thinks that favors
him in this exact position early days
but a tense battle ahead cool and we see
that
lithe is that the name from united
kingdom
adam from malaysia
donated 49
thank you so much to all of you and we
are
hoping to reach our goal of
twenty thousand dollars to give to
unicef and their work in ukraine and
around ukraine
and uh we only have today to do it so
we're gonna need the chess community
we're gonna need all of you to help us
and donate if you have the possibility
to do that so thank you also to ben from
the us donating 31
thank you to all of you paul from
australia wow
all over the world in all of the time
zones yeah it's uh it's really touching
in a way to know that our audience is
worldwide it is so international just
everyone coming together all around the
world uh for a common cause so yeah it's
uh it's really nice to hear it really is
and uh meanwhile magnus did laugh
briefly we're used to seeing that from
him so we won't read too much into it uh
we said that magnus laughing actually
tends to result in mistakes but not
yesterday uh yesterday he was laughing
quite a lot he even fell asleep at one
point
but he did
end up winning the match
so uh maybe that's just how magnus
reacts and just how he kind of helps
himself relax
yeah every player has a different trick
i just relax by trying to not overthink
too much maybe walking around sometimes
but it's hard to walk around in online
chess and
yeah magnus
refocusing yeah duda spending a long
time on this one move yeah we have been
now talking about the opening so
obviously young christophe duda making
his move are you surprised by this one
um slightly there was actually a huge
threat in the position and uh yeah i
think we have to jump in because it
looks like white can actually win a
piece right now it looks like this
knight in the middle middle of the board
is just simply trapped after white
pushes a pawn forward there's no escape
square for this knight but magnus with
his last move has set up a sneaky
counter attack this knight cannot go
anywhere safely and if your piece uh in
chess in general okay we're about to see
this if in chess you find yourself
trapped or attacked you have to counter
attack that's the only way and magnus
reacted by counter-attacking against
white's bishop and uh this bishop now
retreated i don't think you could have
taken this night off because black would
take your bishop and it's more important
that black opens up a really nice line
towards the white king so a trade there
would only favor black and after the
white bishop has retreated suddenly this
black knight which was trapped does have
one escape route it can go back in this
direction and this square now safe
because the white bishop has been cut
off so a really sneaky move there by
magnus just flicking in this kind of
counter-attack against the white bishop
and then
only then deciding whether to remove his
knight in wow
you know he absolutely absolutely hasn't
moved his knight he's moved his rook so
he is sacrificing a piece
in order to get these two magnificent
pawns in the middle of the board and
pressure on the board so we have to yeah
let's keep this on the players as well
maybe if we can while we show this
because is duda going to be shocked he
looks super calm but this is a home idea
from magnus this is some of his home
cooking uh he's definitely studied this
one before i'm not sure if there are any
games uh maybe we can see no games no
game no
but the idea is kind of a little bit
familiar because i myself had an idea
against this uh when i was playing with
the white pieces against uh the greek
grand master catronius okay so uh the
idea if uh if we rewind just a couple of
moves if white had captured this black
knight he hasn't done this duda but if
he had taken it white is a whole night
up but these pawns are simply too scary
and it's not just the fact that the
pawns are scary but magnus having
studied this with a computer that's
psychologically scary for duda he just
felt that these two black pawns were too
strong and instead of capturing
immediately he decides to dodge with his
queen getting out of the eyeline of the
black rook in case things open up and uh
now reinstating this threat against the
knight now the knight is actually
threatened three times by the pawn and
by the white queen and rook so is it
time to retreat now or is magnus going
to continue trying to kind of use this
piece as bait and trying to lure in duda
to accept it in order to open the
position up the problem is you can't
really protect this knight anymore maybe
you have to take a step back with it but
if you take a step back there will be
consequences i think dude's idea is to
push his pawn forward attacking the
black knight and if the knight continues
retreating then this pawn might drop so
really interesting struggle right now
here black has some compensation for the
lost pawn but is it sufficient
can magnus run away with this night
safely or does he have something can i
can i tell you i just took a peek at the
lines to see whether um the computer was
recommending that black move the knight
and the answer is no wow the computer is
saying no it doesn't need to move the
night keep up the night give it up
and uh basically you were saying you
know you can actually develop the dark
square bishop relocate it to a different
diagonal in anticipation of white plain
porn takes night another move is maybe
to put pressure on white's pawn center
by sliding the queen one square over to
the left now yeah
no as an alternative to developing the
remaneuvering the bishops
and uh finally another move is actually
to
uh to indire
to basically push the pawn forward on uh
the alice the a pawn move her two
squares
something but that that's not really
looked well upon so instead the computer
says best moves
slide the queen over or remaneuver the
bishop okay and both of these are
incredibly difficult to find that's why
magnus has stopped right now for two
minutes his first real think of the game
he's either gonna line his queen up with
the white king which is very mysterious
but uh after pawn takes night black does
have options for example of capturing
this white pawn in the center because
this pawn in the middle is pinned
remember it cannot move due to this uh
queen's eye line against the white king
and therefore the pawn can be up for
grabs and this gets really really
complicated
i'm not sure exactly what the idea is to
be honest it looks very inhuman to me
it's the type of thing computers suggest
this one looks very tempting but it
depends on the follow-up white's about
to capture the black knight and the
question is whether black can continue
taking in the center and maybe just
going for some attack very shortly
against the white king just trying to
target the white monarch here i guess
the idea maybe is that if white takes
this pawn white is a whole piece up then
black will just block threatening the
white queen and when the queen retreats
the attack continues and
this is going to be just fireworks on
the board if it happens if magnus keeps
his knight in the center it's just going
to explode into life this game yeah
let's hope he does that because the
alternative retreating with the knight
maybe just not as good there magnus is
surprising us at every turn because uh
yesterday we were surprised by his moves
and now we're surprised by his actual
strategy he's actually gone really hard
in the opening and he's taking big risks
and he's playing very confidently he's
kind of saying hey
i got this under control i'm going to
play as fast as furiously as i can and
let's see whether you you and christoph
can deal with my activity
exciting exciting stuff is it simply a
sign of confidence and also that he's
really enjoying this i think so magnus
loves playing the top players in the
world he loves testing himself um he
loves beating them of course and uh he
loves doing that in as kind of emphatic
a way as possible he wants to show them
who's boss time after time and uh yeah
in this game remember a draw is actually
a fantastic result for magnus with black
he's leading already in the match but as
ivanka mentions he's going hard he's
taking big big risks and
uh you know i think this is instructive
for everyone at home as well if you just
want a draw if you're playing a very
strong opponent don't just play
passively eventually those negative
decisions will impact your game your
opponent will gain confidence they'll
see you a bit scared and they'll
eventually find a way to outplay you or
beat you and uh the best way to actually
get a draw oh he does retreat his knight
the best way to get a draw is often to
play hard to go for the attack later on
you can give a perpetual check later on
your opponent might be the one taking
the negative decisions and okay we are a
bit disappointed to see black's knight
retreat but i think the other moves
unless you've studied them before just
very very difficult to play yeah
and uh well david the idea that you
mentioned wow
we thought the night was going to go
backwards but like you say it's uh being
offered up again as a sacrifice for
opening up those lines and now the
position it's going crazy again yeah and
we mentioned sacrificing that night
magnus sacrificed it but he lost two
moves in the process as well and he did
that simply to force white to push the
yh pawn forward two squares hoping that
the white king is maybe more loose now
lacks pawn shelter and
this is just
i mean how does he come up with this
stuff magnus carlsen giving the opponent
two moves for free in order to force him
to take the knight
dude remember he had rejected the first
gift he didn't take the knight the first
time he could have done and now magnus
has really forced him to if that knight
wasn't captured on the last turn the
knight would have jumped towards the
white king so uh okay really interesting
and now judah's problem is if the white
queen steps up two squares and captures
this black pawn in the middle of the
board black's light square bishop will
come and block forcing the queen away
and then black's remaining pawn will
start advancing towards the king
actually the white king has no
protection around it no pieces white
knights are on the wrong side of the
board yeah totally i mean just look at
those pieces on the left you know in the
words of mikhail tell sleeping so they
are not awakened and whilst you can do
that you should strike while the iron is
hot so an insane game already and whilst
we're waiting for young christoph to
think about what he's going to play um
we have a few selfies that i'd love to
share with you and one from abhishek who
said yesterday was this his son's a five
five-year-old guy's first day at school
i promised to play a chess with him
every day and post his selfie too and
only then did he agree to go
today's kids know all the tricks that is
true they know it on and off the
chessboard i have to say that so nice
picture those are some very cool
sunglasses i have to say they are very
cool yeah and john frederick torp sends
us greetings from mexican mexico and
he's rooting for magnus carlsen of
course but he should have used the
burrito uh emoji oh did it i think wow
look at the evaluation bar just shot up
in black's favor duda could not stand
the tension he took this pawn we
literally just said he couldn't do this
and dude is shaking his head he's
realizing this is a huge mistake because
black i think has got a winning attack
and magnus just instantly blocking this
threat uh of the queen trade with his
bishop we have to jump into the position
let's keep an eye because we might see a
huge reaction the black bishop actually
jumped in the way black could have also
pushed a pawn but black bishop has
jumped in the way and now the queen
retreats it's all about this guy this
guy is going to be a battering ram
opening up the white king magnus is
surely going to throw this pawn forward
and
how is this king ever going to survive
i don't think it will for example this
pawn is actually threatening to move
down the board with another check
hitting the white king hitting the white
rook you have to stop its advance you
either trade it off okay magnus has
played this move you have to trade it
off but then allowing the black rook
into your position attacking the white
queen and when the white queen moves
this is going to be a deadly check i
think this just ends in checkmate uh
white's king is doomed the only one i
can think of to survive here ivanka is
using the white bishop to stop the
advance of this pawn but then after a
simple pawn takes pawn now the black
rook is indeed coming in it's going to
slide down and across and round and it's
going to trap this white king this white
king simply has no defenders and uh i
mean it looks like a very simple plan
here but it does take three moves uh so
duda his last remaining hope is to bring
his knights across to the defense it's
not looking easy even if you bring your
knight across to stop the black rook
using the square the black queen can
attack maybe she can slide across coming
in threatening checkmate
it just looks hopeless this black pawn
is just paralyzing the black the white
king and
looks already winning for the world
champion wow
it does look really really bad
but okay we have to be really concrete
about this because you know if
if white is able to kind of plan some
kind of defense you know the king
can sit there in the corner sing gloria
gaynor's famous tune i will survive
i was inspired by david the king will
survive
and you know
okay so i mean it really is on a threat
by threat basis and like dave is
highlighted in that particular position
the queen is coming in so you have to
defend that that's the only movie you
can make so you have to step back with
the bishop and
it is horrible and uh just to cover the
square it is
it is terrible position it looks so so
scary and all magnus has to do is just
carry on building unfortunately yeah i
mean he can bring his queen into the
attack he can maybe lift his rook
forward line up the other rook behind it
and uh yeah this bishop in the centre of
the board is just a monster we talked
earlier about giving the bishop pair to
magnus this bishop is just the key piece
it keeps an eye on all the light squares
keeps this pawn alive forever and i
don't think dude is really going to
survive us iran conventions there
because it just looks too scary and he's
also shaking his head dude a hand over
his face right now that's always a bad
sign body language wise if a chess
player's got their hand over their head
like that it means they hate their
position they don't even want to look at
the board and uh in the current position
it does feel that way duda lower on the
clock as well
he's in huge trouble right now i have a
question for you about this particular
so you played at this position say let's
pretend that we all young crystal duda
would you be angry with yourself or
would you be furious
i mean
what i meant is like would you be sad
actually i got the question right would
you be sad sad or furious is what i
wanted to ask i ended up saying
i would just be shocked i mean how often
uh are you lost with white in 20 moves
yeah as a world-class player that's just
because i said down to magnus carlsen's
just genius would you call a genius yeah
yeah i mean we'll show it again a bit
later on in action replay but that night
sacrifice okay white meanwhile bring the
bishop across to stop the advance of
this black pawn but that knight
sacrifice maybe we can show it now just
because it was just so incredible we saw
white white attacking this black knight
it retreated the white pawn stepped
forward and now this knight simply came
back to the center of the board magnus
just losing two moves but the whole
reason is now he has a safe square for
the night therefore the knight cannot be
allowed to live and after pawn takes
pawn as we showed this is the game uh
duda here blundering by taking this pawn
it was a very natural blunder we can't
blame him for it but just that
psychological shock he's not recovering
actually i think magnus could have won
the spot on the spot by pushing this
pawn forward even stronger but okay this
bishop move and uh if we fast forward to
the current position this one magnus all
he needs to do as we showed is play pawn
takes pawn and big big attack he could
maybe even start with this queen move
first uh just trying to use the queen on
this diagonal also looks pretty good
actually that looks
really good
i mean the whole position just looks
very good for magnus right now a few
very tempting options bringing the queen
into the attack or capturing this pawn
maybe even alternatives that as well and
uh yeah let's go back to the players
dude
he's on the brink this final might be a
very short one unless he can
miraculously save this game now
because magnus just seems unconfident as
well it doesn't seem like he will make a
blunder at any point no not when he's
playing like this
but that's the thing you know and
yesterday as well when we see how magnus
played it really was a world champion
demonstrating his magnificat
magnificence and when we can kind of
compare his play over the last few days
we see him just getting better and
better and better it's like he's playing
himself into the best form of his life
and uh yeah i'm hats off to the world
champion so far it's been a fantastic
opening wow and uh
well he has to finish it off now this is
the thing yeah but i mean what you've
seen from magnus over in this final
yesterday and today
is it some of the best
yeah we've seen from him i mean the last
time i saw magnus looking this good was
maybe at the beginning of 2019 so just
after his match against fabiano caruana
okay he does play pawn six pawn very
natural move opening up lines for the
black pieces um but yeah the last time i
saw him was when uh he was okay firstly
using that preparation from the match
against caruana but also when he was
inspired by alpha zero this ai program
and magnus said that inspired him to
start pushing pawns forward to taking
risks long-term strategic sacrifices
just like the one he's played now and uh
yeah just something about magnus display
just
it's so powerful it's so energetic and
he doesn't always show it as we as
ivanka mentioned he is a slow starter in
events normally taking a few days to
warm up but
i mean duda he's a world cup winner he's
only 23 he's one of the best in the
world already and magnus is making him
look
just quite ordinary at the moment and he
should be in great shape as well right
probably doing training camps before the
candidates playing a lot of chess
exactly dude i mean he got to be in
great shape to get to the final of one
of these events absolutely there's one
big difference magnus it can be very
open about his opening choices whereas
duda has to actually play hiding his
preparation because he has to leave the
best for the candidate match i mean
you don't want to
use a terrible analogy but gary kasparov
used this when he defeated some a very
strong ground master actually
using some amazing analysis and he later
described it very kind of
condescendingly you know just using a
machine gun to swat a fly
and this is the thing with a duda
doesn't want to use all that preparation
for this type of game yeah he wants it
to be in the killer moment in a crunch
time then he will come with some
fantastic analysis yeah
and dude actually mentioned it in his
interview yesterday right he was not
playing his mainstream openings his main
kind of favorite lines because he is
hiding them and yeah we just see the
evaluation bar slightly
shuffling side to side i think it's
going to recorrect itself and go black
in black's favor but
that just shows the computer even is
struggling to see the depth of magnus's
idea and the computer that we're using
stockfish it does have a certain horizon
so after a while it was like slightly
edged back towards
black but meanwhile magnus again playing
one of the other ideas we mentioned
bringing the queen across there's a
devastating threat the black queen if it
lands on the h3 square in the corner
it's just going to come down and deliver
checkmate user using the pawn next to it
and uh i mean it's so hard to stop that
i think ivanka is right the white bishop
has to move but where white's bishop has
to uh just jump out the way so the white
queen can cover the third rank
there's not many safe squares for that
bishop though and he does retreat it and
this was not the square apparently
because i just peeked at the computer
that was a bit bad and naughty of me but
uh the bishop had to step forward
because i assumed you know could just
step backwards and actually this is not
good okay and the reason why is to
because the bishop needed to maintain
this presence on the diagonal otherwise
black will put his bishop on the h6
square wow okay so let's jump in duda
once again shaking his head as we saw
just then and uh ivanka's mentioning
that in this position the bishop
actually just retreated but it needed to
advance and step to this square this is
not obvious because it looks like the
bishop is about to get trapped and you
have no escape squares for it now unless
you go back where you came from uh so
very naturally dude has retreated his
bishop and you're saying here ivanka now
black can use this diagonal for his
piece and suddenly this block of wood
which was doing nothing staring at white
pawns is coming to life it might remove
a key defender it might even kind of
zigzag towards the white king in a
moment yeah and this looks very scary as
well all of black's pieces are arriving
to the party and white's pieces
didn't get an invite this rook didn't
get invited this knight didn't get
invited either and
white is essentially playing without
those two pieces but whoa
magnus sacrificing his rook is this
continued genius because he's just given
his rook up and after the night yeah
this one's risky though you're giving up
so many pieces after the rope disappears
his idea is to jump in with his queen
threatening this checkmate the whole
reason he gave up the rook was to block
this line so the white queen can't
defend but can you run away can you move
your bishop out the way in order to
create an escape square for the white
king
this one is really tense from dude's
body language he thinks he's losing
magnus thinks he's winning but the
evaluation bar says
the computer making a mockery of us all
maybe the white bishop can move i'm
trying to decide where you have to go
this way or this way i'm not sure which
one maybe this way and uh yes you give
up your bishop but you do create an
escape square for your king magnus is a
rook and a knight down so if he survived
dude then he has a material advantage
i think magnus just trying to be too
flashy there i like ivanka's simple
approach just bring another piece into
the game later the attack for sure will
work you just got to time it correctly
instead magnus going for the attack now
but it might rebound it might backfire
the knight can safely take this rook and
after the black queen jumps in the white
bishop is going to move and whoa okay
duder panicking he gives up his queen
but this is not going to save the game
after the queen is captured he's a whole
queen down and he's facing a withering
attack this is going to threaten
checkmate and the black queen attacking
the white knight
this one is just going to be game over
the white knight has to retreat now and
block but ivanka it's time for your
maneuver yeah bring the bishop in bring
british pin and it's good
that's that's really deadly there's
nothing to be done actually a queen is
always better than no queen and here
magnus has the queen and the attack
let's go back to the players magnus
about to win and uh we can't blame duda
there maybe he had a narrow path to
defend but he's been under pressure this
whole game
magnus about to finish this one off yeah
and uh one thing that we should really
point out is that we have access to the
computer and look magnus he knows he has
to invite everyone to the party and the
bishop is coming into the apple square
with deadly effect because one of the
things is that
you know these days with the
advance of technology we can sit there
and we can look and the computer can
work it off it all out for us and they
can see the bar it can see everything so
we have some extra information the
players don't have and the position was
wild and
what to say i agree i mean it's very
easy to panic in these type of
situations and magnus he's relentless
look at him you know he's determined to
put that bishop on the killer f4 square
and that black rook was the only piece
not attacking now it is attacking not
just bringing the bishop in also black's
rook trying to get rid of white's bishop
white's king is overworked defending two
pieces yeah like ivanka said uh just
having access even just to the
evaluation bar is essential for us we
saw that black's attack was very strong
but then just for one move duda could
have survived but he doesn't know that
he he would have been feeling that
black's attack was strong the whole time
and uh that's why he's been shaking his
head he didn't look for the resources
the defensive resources because he
didn't know they were there we knew that
they were there because of the
evaluation bar and now okay he's
bringing his rook across but he's
shaking his head he knows that this game
is pretty much gone black has
so many winning moves now two of them
would include bringing the black bishop
in to attack that white knight in the
corner and uh the other one maybe using
the black rook taking take the bishop
off
that to me is uh looks good
is there anything to
i mean that looks good as well i mean
the only thing that i can see is that
white could block the rook uh block and
porn that's what i want to say okay just
to show this one because there are a
couple of variations here um the moves
we're looking for for black two killer
moves here bring the bishop in attacking
this white knight and this white knight
remember cannot move if it jumps out the
way then this ends in checkmate so here
you have to get rid of this bishop white
will have to take but if we do a quick
material count black has a queen for
three white pieces
for white knight and bishop but although
three pieces is the same value as a
queen white is just doomed here the
white king is just too much of a target
has no pawns around it to protect and
black still has an attack threatening to
take this bishop for example so this
would win for magnus he's just working
out whether that is simpler than
capturing the white bishop this is
another path to victory because after
the king takes suddenly the knight has
no protection and black is threatening
to make another queen with a discover
check white has to block but
again the king is too open and we
actually have this position on the board
now
among the winning moves would be maybe
stepping back with the black queen just
because you have the killer threat of
jumping back with a check and with a
double attack
white's king cannot save its two rooks
it feels like white's position is just
too loose here i think he has actually
played this killer threat of queen check
winning the white rook
no way to survive now
uh if you step back with the rook for
example the bishop can start coming in
and
this is going to be game over soon pawns
are dropping
it's just too open now the white king
magnus on the brink of a victory wow
yeah uh incredible game by magnus and uh
all due to the opening
wow yeah and some fantastic play by
magnus scrolls and now if magnus wins
this uh he could actually decide the
final in the next game if he wins that
as well so we might not have too much
time left in our fundraising so if you
do have the opportunity to donate to
unicef then now is the time and you can
see the information on the bottom of the
screen thank you to everyone that is
donating and we have some moves
yeah and what a move look at magnus's
full board awareness
he's been attacking the white king the
whole time and then just quietly
suddenly he switches his attentions to
the other side of the board and look at
this black pawn it's just marching down
to dislodge the white knight white
tonight looks like it's an innocent
bystander not doing anything but it is
defending white's central pawns and okay
after black's pawn disappears the black
pawn dislodging the knight will end in
all of white's pawns now falling off the
board the white knight has to move away
and then black's gonna step up with the
black queen capture one pawn with a
check we're gonna see this in action
actually black's gonna take one pawn
with check then black's queen is next
after the white king moves going to grab
white central pawn and just like
dominoes they're all falling
it's actually virtually level material
right now black's queen a new kind of
balancing out the two white rooks but
the black queen's so much more powerful
than white's pieces and there we go
another porn falls black's queen
attacking two pawns now
one of those other pawns will fall
it's just kind of a cleaning up job here
as they say um it's still slightly messy
so you just got to clean things up take
off all your opponent's pawns and slowly
but surely it's a win for black yeah and
uh i mean not only does black have extra
material but also
when you judge these type of positions
with rooks against queens then you also
have to judge a king safety save either
side has an unsafe king then it means
that you're vulnerable and take a look
at white's king out in the open oh and
another porn foul
uh bad news yeah even bad news for uh
dude
keeps coming i mean but he is trying you
know
he is also reminding magnus that
black also has an unsafe king
if given the opportunity but magnus is
relentless he's centralizing the queen
best square for such a piece yup center
of the ball is always good for queens
just look how many squares this queen
controls um white's rooks cannot
actually kick her off using the central
line because the d2 square that the
white rooks both want to use to attack
the black queen is actually covered by
black's bishop so this is also a good
strategy a queen on light squares a
bishop on dark squares together they
just control the whole board and white
does have one check white's rook can
come up to the top of the board checking
the black king but the black king is
hiding safely behind its own pawns it'll
just move off the back rank and
nothing else to do
white has
run out of pawns here simply um it's
five pawns versus two
and slowly but surely as mentioned
blacks pawns are gonna much down this
side maybe much down the other side of
the board the white rooks eventually
will be overstretched and duda is
looking that far into the future he sees
long term he's got no chance so unless
there's a trick now starting with a
check then uh yeah he might even throw
in the towel and resign this game but
okay that check
simply met by a king advance
what else can you try maybe the white
rook can come down to the seventh rank
try to attack some pawns
but uh that can be easily defended as
well by magnus also running out of time
here duda
running out of time he improves the
white king but now the white knight is
pinned this is the problem no matter
where you put the white king there are
downsides the white knight now stuck
because black's queen on a nice diagonal
and it's time for magnus's pawns to
start rolling maybe he'll improve the
black bishop first
spoiler for choice i totally i mean i
would be tempting
just to
push my b pawn push it up two squares
and then threaten to promote alice into
a lovely new queen
looks like on his body language he is
getting ready to resign though young
christophe duda and that will be
dramatic now remember we also have the
auction that will be finished today this
unique sign chessboard by world champion
magnus carlsen is up for grabs current
bid 4 000
and uh well not a lot of time left to
make your bid and remember there's also
a signed air things device by magnus
carlsen on that auction site
cctauction.com current bid on that one
375 dollars
both of them signed by
the player who could be about to win the
charity cup
yeah and uh a really
uh sadistic move here from magnus just
putting his queen into the center once
again but a massive threat the queen's
threatening to slide across two squares
checking the white king but also hitting
that underfunded white rook at the top
of the board queens are so versatile uh
they just have such good eyesight just
looking at all the pieces all over the
board and it's going to be hard for
young christophe duda to keep his pieces
defended keep his kings safe
i mean that's not even mentioned in the
advance of black's pawns that is
incoming i mean
this
not much to say here unfortunately
white's rook at the top of the board has
to find a safe square it's loose you
can't have undefended pieces when your
opponent has a queen so you have to keep
it on a protected square somewhere but
retreating it the whole way back down
being passive that just gives black all
the time in the world to advance the
pawns
uh yeah okay he defends his rook this
way the rook's teaming up at least but
this check forces the white king onto a
dark square and black has that dark
squared bishop and the queen of bishop
teaming up yeah and now it's the knight
that is a target
it's got a mark on his back and uh well
his plan is simply just to start giving
the white king a few checks
and here it comes the king is forced to
take a step backwards but uh yet another
pawn is up for grabs yeah if magnus
wants to be really greedy the white pawn
in the center of the board can just be
captured by the black bishop and there
we go they are falling i mentioned
dominoes those dominoes have completely
toppled over white only has one pawn
remaining black has five pawns
and uh queen versus two rooks as we
mentioned roughly balanced it's all
about the pawns now and the open white
king it's not just having the pawns look
how safe black's king is behind its
pawns look how white is lacking shelter
and uh
have we seen it there i think judah has
resigned it's over magnus carlsen wins
game one in the second match here in the
final and that's super dramatic for
young christof duda he now has to